catholic charities had a packed house as
they served their annual thanksgiving
day meal to the community victoria saha
spoke with those who are thankful for it
the line in front of the dining hall at
catholic charities seemed never ending
everyone waiting to get their hands on a
hot thanksgiving meal i'm grateful to be
here
and just you know have
this opportunity we met guy ellington he
was homeless for a year now in temporary
housing with catholic charities today he
is thankful for all the help he has
received there's a lot of help for
people out here if they want there's a
lot of people that
don't
want it you know a lot of people on
drugs
homeless
stopped me from using governor steve
siselek wanted to help he was in charge
of the pie station while taking a moment
to address the need of food security in
our area this is extremely important to
me you know we've got a lot of people
still in need desperate need a lot of
people living on the streets and people
that don't have food security catholic
charities says they always make about a
thousand meals on thanksgiving and they
have enough for people to get seconds if
they want to but they have to loop
around the line all over again from
outside for many like john blake a
thanksgiving meal doesn't just fill
their tummies but their hearts as well
my mom and dad both passed away from
cancer you know
don't have a lot of family left but
i miss those times especially my mom's
cooking you know
nothing like your mom's cooking on top
of the 1 000 meals served in person
catholic charities also delivered 2 400
meals on wheels turkey dressing and
cranberry sauce my first top three i
have to have those three extra cranberry
sauce too victoria saha live local now